THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ACOSTA.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN IRAN BELA. BAKER.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW. BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRAVO.
FOR FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA. IT'S IN.
GLORIA GONZALEZ-FLETCHER GRAIN.
HARPER.
HOLDEN. IRWIN JONES-SAWYER.
KALRA.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMóN.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MIRTH SU CHI NOW
VERY EN. OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL AYE
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK-SILVA. RARES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SOLACE SANTIAGO STEINORTH.
STONE.
THERE ARE MEN'S TEEING BOTH
SHALL.
WALDRON WEBER. WOULD MISTER
SPEAKER.
QUOTE MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
AND THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAY'S PRAYER WE OFFERED BY
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN. REVEREND BOB
OSHA.
REVENUE OCEAN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION AS WE OPENED OUR
FIRST ASSEMBLY FLOOR SESSION.
FOR THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
I WAS SURPRISED TO LEARN THAT
THE EARLIEST KNOWN CALENDAR
FOUND SO FAR. DATES BACK ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND YEARS AND WAS
FOUNDED SCOTLAND.
TEN THOUSAND YEARS COINCIDES
PERFECTLY WITH THE TIME THAT
HUMAN BEINGS WERE TRANSITIONING
FROM LIVING IN THE MEDIC TRIBES.
TWO LIVING IN SETTLED AGRARIAN
COMMUNITIES.
DOMESTICATING ANIMALS PLANTING
CROPS.
THE SOCIETIES BASED ON
AGRICULTURE THE MEASURING UP
TIME BECAME BECAME AN IMPORTANT
CONCERN.
IT WAS ESSENTIAL TO KNOW WHEN TO
PLANT THEIR CROPS
IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL HARVEST.
BECAUSE OF THIS.
CONCEPT OF HAVING A CALENDAR
YEAR WAS CREATED BY HUMANITY. TO
GIVE A SENSE OF ORDER TO THE
PASSAGE OF TIME.
THEY GOT THE WORD YEAR MEANS
SEASON.
SO EVERY NEW YEAR. MARKED THE
BEGINNING OF A NEW CYCLE OF
SEASONS.
TO PLAN.
CULTIVATE AND HARVEST LIFE
SUSTAINING CRACKS.
WE RARELY GIVE THOUGHT TO HOW OR
WHY HUMANKIND BEGAN TO MARK THE
PASSAGE OF TIME WITH AN ONGOING
CYCLE OF BEGINNINGS AND ENDINGS.
BUT ALL THE CALENDARS THAT HAVE
EVER EXISTED. REFLECT HUMANITIES
ATTEMPTS
TO MARK THE PASSING OF TIME.
TIME THAT IS INFINITE.
WITH OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN WE SEE
THAT EVERY MOMENT IS A NEW
BEGINNING. AND EVERY MOMENT CAN
MARK AN ENDING.
WITH OUR WISDOM ICE OPEN. LET US
ALL TRY.
TO LIVE APPRECIATING EACH NEW
DAY. AND EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE APART OF A POSITIVE NEW
BEGINNING IN THE NEW YEAR AHEAD.
NOW MORE MEET UP.
WITH THE KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND.
THANK YOU.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
TO REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
JOIN ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORREO AS
SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
RIGHT.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
THE FLAG.
HE MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS ACT.
SOON TO THE PROVISIONS OF JOINT
WELL FIFTY NINE THE FOLLOWING
SEMESTER CALDERON MOVES AND
MISTER DALI SECONDS AT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL SO BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NINE. MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
MOTIONS AND REVEL RESOLUTIONS MR
CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY BILL
ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORIO. GIPSON
KANSEN CHU AS WELL AS GALLAGHER
TO HAVE GUESTS OF THE TALK WAS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS KOREA CHEWING
GALLAGHER'S GAS WILL BE SEATED
AT THEIR DESKS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
A REQUEST IS GRANTED.
ABSENT SAYS FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLYMEMBER BAKER
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER.
MR CALDERON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR MOTIONS
.
MEMBERS IT IS MY PRIVILEGE TO
INTRODUCE
THE NEWEST MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
INTRODUCING THE NEWEST MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF
ADMINISTERING THE OATH OF OFFICE
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER WENDY KOREA A
FEW WEEKS AGO.
SHE WILL BE ENABLE REPLACEMENT
FOR HER PREDECESSOR JIMMY GOMEZ
WHO IS NOW REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA. IN CONGRESS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT SHE HAS
ALRADY ACCOMPLISHED YOU CAN
TELL ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORREO COMES
TO US WITH A LOT OF ENERGY AND A
LOT OF KNOWLEDGE.
NOBODY WILL BE A BETTER
REPRESENTATIVE OF CALIFORNIA'S
DREAMERS BECAUSE SHE KNOWS WHAT
IT TAKES TO SUCCEED AFTER COMING
HERE AS UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
SHE'S GOING TO BE STRONG STRONG
IN TERMS OF STANDING UP FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
STRONG IN TERMS OF STANDING UP
FOR WORKING PEOPLE AND STRONG IN
TERMS OF WORK STANDING UP FOR
WOMEN.
AND NOW LET ME ASK HER TO STAND
UP TO BE WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WENDY KOREA
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAREER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS AND FOR SOME BRIEF
REMARKS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUES AND
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS.
WHAT AN HONOR AND PRIVILEGE TO
STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY PROBABLY
REPRESENTING THE FIFTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT? OF EAST LOS
ANGELES NORTHEAST LA. EL SERENO.
ECHO PARK APART THE FILLER
SILVERLAKE.
AND OF COURSE THE INCREDIBLE AND
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES OF THE
DISTRICT INCLUDING DODGER
STADIUM GO DODGERS.
THIS IS THE DISTRICT WHERE I
GREW UP WHERE I LIVE.
AND I AM HUMBLED TO HAVE EARNED
THE SUPPORT OF THE VOTERS WHO
HAVE ENTRUSTED IN ME WITH ITS
CARE.
I STAND HERE AND WONDER.
THINKING ABOUT THE LATIN WORDS
INSCRIBED IN GOLD ABOVE THE
DIETS.
THE MODEL OF THIS HOUSE.
IT IS THE DUTY.
OF THE LEGISLATORS TO PASS JUST
LOS.
IN THIS MOMENT.
IN OUR NATION'S HISTORY WHEN
WOMEN. IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES
MINORITY GROUPS.
AND THE WORLD IN WHICH WE LIVE
IN IS THREATENED EVERY DAY.
I FIND THE RESPONSIBILITY.
OF GOVERNING QUITE HUMBLING.
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT WE MUST
PROTECT THOSE THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE.
ARE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
SOCIETY. AND THOSE WHOSE VOICES
NEED TO BE AMPLIFIED.
LIKE MANY ACROSS OUR NATION I
CAME TO THIS COUNTRY WHEN I WAS
A YOUNG CHILD.
MY MOTHER IS SUMMER SLOWED MY
FATHER SOMETHING LIKE THAT THEY
BECAUSE MAKING GOING I WAS BORN.
IN THE CELLAR DURING A TERRIBLE
CIVIL WAR.
I CAME TO THIS COUNTRY WHEN I
WAS FIVE.
BETWEEN THE AGES FIVE AND
THIRTEEN I WAS UNDOCUMENTED BUT
I HAD A PATHWAY TO RESIDENCY.
AND CITIZENSHIP WHICH HAVE
ALLOWED ME TO BE HERE. WITH YOU
ALL TODAY.
I RECOGNIZE.
THAT THIS IS NOT A UNIQUE STORY
IT IS THE STORY OF.
MILLIONS.
PEOPLE ACROSS THIS NATION WHO
BELIEVE. AND WANT TO FIGHT FOR
THE BEST FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEMSELVES.
IT IS THE STORY.
OF THE EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DACA RECIPIENTS WHOSE.
FATE IS UNKNOWN RIGHT NOW.
IT IS THE DUTY OF THIS GOVERNING
BODY TO PASS
JUST LAWS.
AND A SOMEONE WHO HAS WALKED
THIS ROAD.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
JOURNEY AHEAD ENSURING THAT WE
ARE FIGHTING FOR OPPORTUNITY
JUSTICE AND EQUITY. FOR WORKING
FAMILIES FOR STUDENTS.
AND FOR EVERYONE WHO CALLS
CALIFORNIA HOME.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF YOU MY NEW
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE REACHED OUT
AND HAVE OFFERED. WORDS OF
WISDOM AND ENCOURAGEMENT IN THIS
TIME.
THANK YOU TO ALL OF MY
SUPPORTERS WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
TO MY SEIU LABOR FAMILY WHO'S
HERE AND ALL OF THE LABOR UNIONS
ACROSS OUR STATE WHO STOOD UP.
AND WITH THE TOGETHER FOR THE
VALUES THE WORKING CLASS
PROGRESSIVE FAMILIES ACROSS OUR
DISTRICT IN OUR STATE.
THANK YOU TO MY PARENTS.
WHO HAVE TAUGHT?
TAUGHT ME AND MY MY SISTER'S.
THE PERSIST TO PERSEVERE TO HAVE
COURAGE.
AND TO MOVE FORWARD.
THIS MOMENT.
IS THERE MOMENT JUST AS IT IS
MINE AND IT IS AN HONOR.
TO BE HERE REPRESENTING OUR
ANCESTORS.
AND THE MANY SACRIFICES THAT MY
PARENTS AND WORKING FAMILIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
HAVE MADE TO ENSURE THAT A NEW
GENERATION OF AMERICANS HAVE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY DID NOT.
I MEAN SPOTLESS FOR LANDED
AUTOMATICALLY ON A SCALE OF GAS
YES.
BOARD ANATOMY AYE MEDIUM IS SAID
MINUS.
ONE EXAMPLE THE FROM MEDIA.
THAT THE LITTLE NOT ONLY THAT
THE I MODE. FOURTEEN SONGS.
IT YOU'LL THAT ON THEIR NAMES.
THEN THING AND MICHAEL GOT UP AT
THE LAWFUL POLITICAL SEAL IN THE
STUDY.
YOU GOTTA KFC LITHOGRAPHY SU
PICKLE MINSAW SO MUCH SCIENCE.
HE HAD FRUIT THOUGH I SEE THAT
ARE GOING.
IT'S BETTER OKAY YET AND CNN
THAT WILL YOU MAKE IT IS
WRITTEN.
LOOK ALCATEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER FOR
ALLOWING ME THIS TIME I LOOK
FORWARD TO WHAT THE JOURNEY
AHEAD LOOKS LIKE AND WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE WORKING.
FOR EVERY PERSON
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HOMAN
ENSURING THAT WORKING CLASS
PROGRESSIVE VALUES ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE CONVERSATION.
WHEN IT COMES TO ENSURING THE
NEXT STEPS FOR OUR STATE THANK
YOU
.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER WORK
SIDE TO HAVE YOU JOIN US AND
WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO EXTEND A
SPECIAL WELCOME TO YOUR PARENTS
TODAY. MR CALDERON YOU MAY
PROCEED WITH YOUR ADDITIONAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST ANONYMOUS CONSENT
SUSPENDED SEVERAL FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE AND ALLOW.
THE SPEAKER AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
WOULD AGUIAR-CURRY GALLAGHER AND
THE MOAN AND. TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT AND MEMBER
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH A MEETING
ORDER. PURSUANT ASSEMBLY WILL
NINETY SIX A REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO REFER THE FOLLOWING
BILLS COMMITTEE.
AB THREE OR SIX
GONZALEZ-FLETCHER FROM THE
STERNS COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AB FOR TWENTY SEVEN RESEARCHING
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AB FOUR SEVENTY NINE
GONZALEZ-FLETCHER FROM THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE AB SIX
AWAY.
ONE FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE TO THE BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE. AB EIGHT
SIXTY FIVE LEVINE FROM THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO RULES COMMITTEE. AB
EIGHT SEVENTY LEVINE FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE AB EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT LOW FROM HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AB NINE SIX IT TO ALAN FROM THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
COMMITTEE TO THE JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN AN ECONOMY
COMMITTEE AND THEN BACK TO THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE.
AB TWELVE A. B. TEN TWENTY FIVE
RUBIO FROM THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTY TEN THIRTY NINE
QUIRK-SILVA FROM THE HUMAN RACE
HOOK HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
AB TWELVE FORTY EIGHT GLORIA
FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE QUIRK-SILVA
FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOR
GONZALEZ-FLETCHER FROM THE
ASSURANCE COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE AB FIFTEEN NINETY SIX
GLORIA FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE TO THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE. AB SIXTEEN
FORTY FIVE ARE TUTSI FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL TO SAFETY IN TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE TO THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH A BE THE
ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY THREE AB
SEVENTY ONE DAVID CHIU TO THE
INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SPEND
ASSEMBLY WILL FIFTY SIX ON THE
FOLLOWING BILLS.
TO ALLOW THE COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE COMMITTEE TO NOTICE
AB AT SEVENTEEN. FOR THEIR
JANUARY TEN HEARING PENDING RE
REFERRAL FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO NOTICE
AB FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN COMING
YADDO FROM THEIR JANUARY TEN
HEARING PENDING RIVER FOR A FROM
THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TALKS MATERIALS COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB FIFTY
FIFTY TO QUIRK-SILVA FROM THE
JANUARY ELEVEN HEARING PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THE ECONOMY
COMMITTEE. AND TO ALLOW THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE AB NINE SIXTY TWO ALLEN
FOR THE JANUARY TENTH HEARING.
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN ECONOMY
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH A MEDIA
ORDER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS
PLEASE REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
ITEM A THREE AB EIGHT EIGHTY
NINE STONE AND ITEM A TEN AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY SIX LIVING.
ONE DAY CLERK WHEN THEY NOTICED
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
I'D LIKE LIKE TO RECOGNIZE AT
THIS TIME MEMBERS FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PEDRO NAVA ON THE
FLOOR.
LET'S GOING TO CAST
INTRODUCTIONS.
MR GIPSON YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GUEST INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TOOK THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOGNIZE MY
CHIEF OF STAFF. ARE MARK LOHMAN
LEE.
WHO'S JOINED US TODAY WITH HIS
FAMILY WHO'S WHO'S STANDING OR
THOSE IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE
STAND.
HERE WITH US IN THE GALLERY WE
HAVE HIS WIFE PEARL.
HIS DAUGHTER ARIANNA. HIS MOTHER
ROSE AND HIS FATHER ARGUED.
THIS IS A SPECIAL TIME OF THE
LOMA LEAVE FAMILY.
IS SPENDING HERE. OF ONE
GLOBALLY IS EXPECTING A BABY
GIRL.
AND I'M SAD TO SAY THAT
MARGOLIES MY CHIEF OF STAFF WILL
BE DEPARTING.
TO PURSUE A CAREER. OUTSIDE THIS
BUILDING.
LET ME JUST SAY THE MARK LOCALLY
HAS CERTAINLY BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
LEADER. BOTH TO OUR STAFF AND
ALSO TO THE COMMUNITY AND ALSO A
VERY REMARKABLE FRIEND.
I WOULD THINK HIS WIFE AND HIS
MOTHER AND FATHER THE ONE
SHARING YOUR TIME.
WITH ALL OF US THE RESIDENTS OF
THIS
SUPPORT DISTRICT.
CERTAINLY WITH MARK BEING AT THE
HELM OF THE CHIEF OF STAFF.
I'M CERTAINLY HAS LEFT US IN A
BETTER PLACE
AND ONE A TAKE UP MOMENT JUST TO
THANK HIM FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO
THE RESIDENTS. OF THE SIXTY FOUR
DISTRICT MARK YOU WILL BE MISSED
BUT WE KNOW THAT THE BEST IS YET
TO COME MEMBERS CAN YOU PLEASE
HELP ME WELCOME THE LITTLE
BELIEVE FAMILY WHOSE THAT STANDS
AT A GALLERY. THIS GIVE THEM A
WARM ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MR GIPSON.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IT'S
GREAT TO BE BACK WITH YOU ALL
THIS MORNING AND I DO HAVE TWO
SPECIAL GUESTS WITH ME THIS
MORNING MY DAUGHTER'S.
KATHERINE AND MAGGIE.
SO GO AHEAD AND STAND UP GUYS
AND.
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER AND
WELCOME BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE ALL ITEMS WILL BE PASTOR
RETAINED.
FOLLOW NEW MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR STATE
FOR THE STATE ASSEMBLY AS THE
STATE ASSEMBLY MOVES TO THE
MEMORIAL TRIBUTE. FOR THE
VICTIMS OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES OF OCTOBER
AND THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES WHICH ARE FINALLY
NEARING CONTAINMENT.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
.
BEFORE WE DO THAT WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL MOTION TO MAKE MR
CONNOR RUNS RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I'D LIKE TO
RESEARCH.
SIMPLY WILL FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
YOU NOTICE IT.
FIVE SEVEN SEVEN CAVALLERO
THE GENERAL TENTH HEARING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU OKAY MEMBERS LET'S GO
TO OUR TRIBUTE TO THE MEMORIAL
FIVE FIRES.
CALIFORNIA'S TRULY A GREAT STATE
BUT IT ALSO FACES SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES.
IN THE PAST FEW MONTHS OUR STATE
HAS BEEN HIT BY UNPRECEDENTED
WILDFIRES.
THEY ARE UNPRECEDENTED IN THEIR
TIMING. UNPRECEDENTED THEIR
SCOPE AND IN THEIR SIZE.
AND ALSO IN TERMS OF HOW THEY
COST THE LIVES
SO MANY VICTIMS.
THESE FIRES HAVE TAKEN FROM US
FIREFIGHTERS
PARENTS.
RETIREES
AND CHILDREN.
WHILE WE WORK TO PREVENT AND
LESS IN THE IMPACTS OF FUTURE
FIRES. WE RECOGNIZE THAT THEIR
SEVERITY IN THEIR TIMING.
APPEARS DUE AT LEAST BE
PARTIALLY RELATED TO CLIMATE
CHANGES THAT HAVE COME AT THE
HANDS OF HUMAN ACTIONS.
WE HAVE TO KEEP WORKING TO
PREVENT NEEDLESS DEATHS WE ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT LIVING IN OUR
BEAUTIFUL STATE. MEANS LIVING
WITH EARTH QUAKES WITH FLAGS
WITH FIRES AND WITH DROUGHT.
WE DO NOT CONTROL NATURE WE CAN
ONLY ATTEMPT TO ADAPT OUR
SURROUNDINGS TO LIVE SAFELY WITH
NATURE.
IT IS OUR SOMBER DUTY TO
REMEMBER THOSE WHO HAVE DIED.
WHEN NATURE IGNORES THOSE
ATTEMPTS.
DOCTOR WOULD. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY WE HONOR THE MANY PEOPLE
AFFECTED BY THE TRAGIC WILDFIRES
TO A CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR.
NO SOONER WERE THE HORRIFIC
FIRES CONTAINED IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THAT WILDFIRES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BEGAN.
IN MY DISTRICT ALONE WE LOST
THIRTY ONE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY MANY OF WHOM WERE
ELDERLY.
ROY IN IRMA BOWMAN EIGHTY EIGHT
AND EIGHTY NINE WERE FROM
REDWOOD VALLEY WOULD GO ON
REGULAR WALKS IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
ALWAYS HOLDING HANDS.
RECALLED HIS WIFE LOLLIPOP AND
SHE REFERRED TO HIM AS HIS AS
HER KNIGHT IN SHINING ARMOR
ARMOR.
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD HIGH SHEPHERD
WAS A MIDDLE SCHOOL STUDENT
EAGLE PARTS EAGLE PEAK MIDDLE
SCHOOL IN REDWOOD VALLEY.
WHO WAS ON THE WRESTLING TEAM
AND INJURED? JOINT
QUARTERBACKING EARLY MORNING
INFORMAL TOUCH FOOTBALL GAMES.
SANTA ROSA RESIDENT TALK FOO
HUNG. AT ONE HUNDRED AND ONE.
GOT AS FAR AS HIS FRONT DOOR AND
IS BURNING FOUND GROVE HOME.
BEFORE TELL HIS WIFE TO RUN FOR
SAFETY.
IN HIS YOUTH HE FILES A GENERAL
AGAINST MAO ZEDONG'S
REVOLUTIONARY ARMY.
I COULD GO ON AND ON.
ALTHOUGH THIS IS DISTRICTS
REMIND US OF THE SIZE OF THE
DISASTER YOU CAN NOT DESCRIBE
THE LOSS AND DEVASTATION THE
COMMUNITY HAS FELT.
PEOPLE LOS MORE THAN THEIR HOMES
IN THEIR BUSINESSES.
THEY BOTH WORKED FOR YEARS TO
BUILD HOUSES FOR THEIR FOR THEIR
HOMES AND MAKE THEIR BUSINESSES
THE FABRIC OF OUR ECONOMY. AND
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR COMMUNITY.
WHILE I WAS ON THE GROUND IN
CINNAMON MENDOCINO COUNTY AFTER
THE FIRES.
I WAS SO IMPRESSED AND TOUCHED
BY THE DEDICATION OF OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS THE FIREFIGHTERS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS.
COUNTY AND CITY OFFICIALS.
UTILITY WORKERS EVERYDAY FOLKS
BOTH LOCAL AND FROM OUTSIDE THE
AREA WHO PITCHED IN TO
VOLUNTEER.
AND DO WHATEVER WAS NEEDED.
WE HAD PEOPLE FROM ALL ACROSS
THE STATE. ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND EVEN FROM
INTERNATIONAL VENUES TO HELP US
AND CAME TO SUPPORT US.
THE TRAUMA OF THOSE WHO LOST
LOVED ONES AND FRIENDS.
AND THOSE WHO LOST THEIR HOMES
AND BUSINESSES WILL BE WITH THEM
FOR A VERY LONG TIME.
I HOPE THEY WILL REACH OUT FOR
HELP IF THEY NEED US.
AND FOR THOSE SORTS WHO WERE
SPARED WE MUST DO WHATEVER WE
CAN TO HELP REBUILD AND RESTORE
THEIR LIVES.
THAT A IS THAT IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
I SAW I FELT THE COMING TOGETHER
AS A COMMUNITY AND IS
CALIFORNIA'S THAT I HAVE NOT
EXPERIENCED IN QUITE SOMETIME.
I HOPE WE HONOR THOSE WHO LOST
SO MUCH.
BY HANGING ON TO THOSE FEELINGS
AND RECOGNIZE THE STRENGTH THAT
COMES FROM THE PEOPLE FROM
PEOPLE COMING TO GATHER. IN THE
FACE OF ADVERSITY.
IOWA AND OTHER COLLEAGUES WHO
FOLLOW ME LAST WINTER IN MEMORY
OF THOSE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES
THINK.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD MS
AGUIAR-CURRY YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
WHO WOULDA THOUGHT AS WE SIT
HERE IN THIS ROOM? YOU'D EVER
FACE A CATASTROPHIC EVENT.
I NEVER DID.
UNTIL THAT UGLY DAY IN OCTOBER.
THAT LASTED FOR THIRTY DAYS.
IT WAS A IT WAS A NIGHTMARE.
IT WAS SO HARD TO SEE PEOPLE
GOING BACK TO THEIR HOMES.
AND WATCH THEM FALL TO THEIR
KNEES CRYING BECAUSE IT LOST
EVERYTHING THAT WORK FOR.
IT'S HARDER SEE ELDERLY BUT
DIDN'T HAVE A PLACE TO GO HOME
TO.
THERE ARE NOW WONDERING WHETHER
GOING TO GO BECAUSE IT ALL THE
LOT OF THEY LOST ALL THEIR
SAVINGS.
BUT A LOT OF GOOD THAT CAME OUT
OF THIS.
AND I IT I WOULD LIKE TO THINK.
MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD WHO WAS.
BY MY SIDE THROUGHOUT THIS EVENT
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOOD.
AND ALL A ALSO CONGRESSMAN
THOMPSON WHO GUIDED ME ALONG THE
WAY BECAUSE I TO AS MANY OF US
HAVE NEVER EXPERIENCED SOMETHING
LIKE THIS.
THE FIRST RESPONDERS OUR STATE
AGENCIES WERE PHENOMENAL.
THEY WERE PHENOMENAL.
A FEDERAL FRIENDS FEMA CAME TO
OUR AID IMMEDIATELY.
CAN WE DO THINGS BETTER O.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT AND
WE'RE GONNA LARN FROM THESE
LESSONS BUT WE NEED TO LEARN
SOON BECAUSE CLIMATE CHANGE IS
UPON US.
WE NEED TO IDENTIFY THE SING
SOONER THAN LATER.
YOU NOW WHEN YOU SIT AND YOU
WATCH THOSE PEOPLE GO HOME. THAN
YOU THINK YOU GET TO GO HOME TO
YOUR HOUSE
AND DURING THE HOLIDAYS I HAVE
MY TOUGHEST TIME.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T TALK ABOUT
THIS AND I THINK SOME OF US WILL
SAY THAT YOU DON'T TALK ABOUT.
BECAUSE YOU JUST GO DO YOUR JOB
IN SHOW YOUR STRENGTH.
AND THEN WHEN YOU GET TO GO HOME
FINALLY KNEW GOING TO YOUR
THANKSGIVING DINNER AND ALL OF
SUDDEN REALLY HIT YOU THINKING
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE AREN'T
GOING HOME.
TO HOUSE
TO WHAT THEY'RE USED TO.
THE COMMUNITY COMES TOGETHER IN
THESE TIMES AND I WANT TO SAY.
THAT IT HAS BUILT COMMUNITY I
HAD FOUR COUNTIES IN FIVE ON
FIRE AT ONE TIME.
EFFECTIVE MY ALMOST MY ENTIRE
DISTRICT.
SO TO ALL OF YOU IS THEM PLEASE
TAKE WARNING.
THE USER UPON THAT'S THESE TIMES
ARE UPON US AND WE NEED TO COME
UP WITH SOME GREAT IDEAS AND
THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX.
HOW WE CAN AT LEAST MAKE THESE
EVENTS AND NOT AS DIFFICULT?
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ALL THINK TO REMIND
OURSELVES OF ALL THOSE THAT LOST
THEIR LIVES AS WELL AS OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS AND EVERYONE THAT
HELPED ON THOSE FIRES. THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU RESIDE HERE CURRY
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES AS WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY HAVE.
AD THE VICTIMS OF THESE
DEVASTATING FIRES THAT.
TOUCHED EVERYONE THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE.
.
THE CASCADE FIRE AND YUBA COUNTY
WAS.
YET ANOTHER.
.
DISASTER THAT WE FACED IN MY
DISTRICT THIS YEAR AS YOU KNOW
EARLY IN THE YEAR WE HAD.
AN EVACUATION OF HER EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH ORVILLE
DAM.
THE THREATS OF FLOODS YOU HAD
OTHER FIRES IN THE CASCADE FIRE.
THAT BLUE THROUGH THE COMMUNITY
OF LUMBER RICA LITERALLY
OVERNIGHT.
.
AS.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WERE SLEEPING.
AWOKE TO THE FACT THAT.
VERY QUICK BURNING GRASS FIRE
HAD.
ESCALATED AND MOVED RIGHT
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY INCLUDING
MY COUSIN.
THE NEXT MORNING I. SAW THE
NEWS ON YA I'D I'D GONE TO BED
THAT NIGHT NOT KNOWING ABOUT.
THIS FIRE.
BUT IMMEDIATELY TEXAN MY COUSIN.
IT SAID ARE YOU OK AND SHE SAID
WE GOT OUT OF SAFE BUT THE HOUSE
IS GONE.
AND AND THAT WAS A STORY FOR SO
MANY FAMILIES.
.
NINE YUBA COUNTY.
ALSO FIRES A DEVASTATED BUTTE
COUNTY AS WELL.
AND THEN WE LOST.
NOW FOR MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
AS WELL.
AS STANLEY COOLIDGE AND ESTEEMED
ATTORNEY FROM THE AREA WHO
ACTUALLY HAD.
HAD FOUGHT FOR FLOOD VICTIMS AND
ONE FOR VICTIMS OF THE YUBA CITY
BUS CRASH.
NOW ROSEANNE HANNAH.
HIS FIANCE.
A DEVOTED MOTHER AND LOVING
FRIEND.
SANDRA PICCIANO.
WHO IS KNOWN AS A WOMAN AT THE
HEART OF GOLD?
AND DAVID COLE A VIETNAM
VETERAN.
THE LOSS OF LIFE THAT WE SAW
HERE THE DEVASTATION OF
FAMILIES.
IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT NO
ONE WANTS TO SEE.
AND.
BUT IS WAS HAVE BY MY COLLEAGUE
SAID THAT THE GATHERING TOGETHER
THE COMMUNITY AND WE ARE SO
THANKFUL TO THE FIRST
RESPONDERS.
GOING FROM OUR LOCAL SHERIFF'S.
AND FIRE.
.
NO.
SERVICEMEN ALL THE WAY UP TO.
STATE RESPONDERS.
THROUGH CAL EMA.
CALIFORNIA ARE.
.
AND AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO FEMA
NOW THAT THE RELIEF EFFORT HAS
BEEN. VERY HELPFUL.
EVERYBODY IS COME TOGETHER TO
HELP ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
REBUILD.
OF THAT WE CAN MOVE TOGETHER AS
COMMUNITIES AND SO. I THINK YOU
MEMBERS FOR FOR JOINING US AS WE
RETURN AND AND MEMORY OF THE
VICTIMS.
OF THESE DEVASTATING FIRES.
AND I THINK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR
SUPPORT. AND THAT'S WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH A VERY TOUGH.
AND A TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO A YEAR OF
REBUILDING.
OF PEACE.
AND PROSPERITY THINKING.
THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER. MS THE
MOUND YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU SPEAKER.
THE THOMAS FIRE HAS BEEN THE
LARGEST.
FIRE IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY.
WE LOST OVER A THOUSAND
STRUCTURES AND WE LOST TWO
INDIVIDUALS DURING THIS FIRE.
BUT I AM REMINDED BY THE FIRE
AND BY MY COLLEAGUES ALL
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
COLLEAGUES WHO REACHED OUT
DURING THIS TIME.
THAT WE ARE CALIFORNIA STRONG.
AND THE IN A TIME OF DISASTER.
WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WILL COME UP AND STEP UP TO
HELP OUR COMMUNITY?
LIKE A SPANISH LANGUAGE
TRANSLATOR WHO LOST HER HOME AND
EVERYTHING SHE OWNED BUT
ATTENDED EVERY MEETING.
AND EVERY COMMUNITY GATHERING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS ACCESS
TO SPANISH LANGUAGE INFORMATION
FOR A COMMUNITY.
WE ALSO LAS TO INDIVIDUALS.
VIRGINIA PISTOLA OF SANTA PAULA.
THE SOLO IS A RETIRED ATTORNEY
I'LL AND WAS A LONG TIME PUBLIC
SERVANT FOR OUR COMMUNITY.
WORKING FOR VENTURA COURTS OF
APPEAL FOR TWELVE YEARS AS WELL
AS SANTA BARBARA COUNTY COUNCIL.
SHE WAS REMEMBERED BY THOSE WHO
KNEW HER AS A SMART.
FIERCE UNIQUELY STYLISH WOMAN
WITH THE STOCK A STRONG SENSE OF
INTEGRITY.
TRAGICALLY.
SHE DIED WHILE EVACUATING FROM
THE THOMAS FIRE.
SHE WILL BE MISSED BY HER NIECES
AND NEPHEWS WHO SAW HER AS A
MOTHER FIGURE.
ADDITIONALLY I SHARING GRIEF
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM ESCONDIDO
THE LOSS OF CALIFORNIA ENGINEER
COREY IVERSON.
IVERSON WAS A PART OF A STRIKE
TEAM THAT WAS AN ACTIVE AREA OF
THE THOMAS FIRE IN THE BEAUTIFUL
CITY OF CELLMARK IN VENTURA
COUNTY WHEN HE DIED ON THE LINE
OF DUTY.
AT THIRTY TWO YEARS OLD IVERSON
WAS AN EIGHT YEAR VETERAN OF CAL
FIRE AND HAD SERVED ANOTHER
SEVEN YEARS WITH HARMONY GROWTH
FIRE DEPARTMENT.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
ACTUALLY AND THEIR TWO YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER.
THE COUPLE WAS EXPECTING THEIR
SECOND CHILD IN ME.
THE BRAVERY AND SERVICE OF COREY
IVERSON WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN.
THANK YOU MS LEMOND. MS WALDRON
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
WHILE MY DISTRICT WAS BEING
DEVASTATED BY THE LILAC FIRE AND
THE LOSS OF SO MANY STRUCTURES
IN HOMES AND THE ELDERLY. WE GOT
WORD OF THE PASSING OF A FIRE
ENGINEER COREY IVERSON FROM MY
DISTRICT.
SO TODAY I RISE IN MEMORY OF
KOREA IVERSON A CAL FIRE SAN
DIEGO UNIT APPARATUS ENGINEER.
RESIDENT OF MY DISTRICT LOVING
HUSBAND FATHER BROTHER A MAN OF
FAITH DIED DECEMBER FOURTH WILL
BRIEFLY BATTLING THE DEVASTATING
THOMAS WILDFIRE.
HE WAS THIRTY TWO WITHIN AMAZING
BEAUTIFUL WIFE ASHLEY THE SWEET
DAUGHTER BABY ON THE WAY.
HIS MOTHER FATHER STEPFATHER
BROTHER LUKE SISTER AN EXTENDED
FAMILY MISS HIM AND CELEBRATE
HIS LIFE.
AS IN ORANGE GOING HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE HE IS NOW OUR HOMETOWN
HERO.
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE IT IS
APPROPRIATE THAT AT THIS TIME TO
PAY TRIBUTE TO HIM A FALLEN
HERO.
BY RECALLING HIS DEVOTION
CELEBRATING HIS LIFE BOOM AND
HONORING HIS SERVICE.
CORY IVERSON WAS IN ESCONDIDO
RESIDENT AND DISCOVERED HIS
PASSION FOR FIRE SERVICE BY
FOLLOWING IN HIS UNCLE'S
FOOTSTEPS.
HE WAS STEADFAST AND COMMITTED.
TO BEING THE BEST FIREFIGHTER HE
COULD BE AND ALWAYS STRIVING TO%
LEARN AND DO MORE EVEN BECOMING
ONE OF THOSE FRONTLINE
FIREFIGHTERS DROPPING FROM A
HELICOPTER. ON TO THE FRONT LINE
OF THE SURGING FLAMES.
IVERSON JOINT HELLFIRE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE IF THE WORKING FOR
THE HARMONY GIRL FIRE
DEPARTMENT.
IN MY DISTRICT FOR SEVEN YEARS.
WINONA MORRELL PORTENT NO.
CORY WAS A MAN OF FAITH WHO
DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO SHARING THE
LOVE OF JESUS.
HE WAS FULLY PRESENT WITH OTHERS
INSPIRING OTHERS TO ALWAYS
STRIVE FOR SOMETHING GREATER.
AND LED BY WALKING IN DOING LIFE
WITH HIS BROTHERS AND CAL FIVE.
I ATTENDED HIS.
SERVICE WITH MANY OTHER OF OUR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO ARE PRESENT.
AND THEY AMOUNT OF SUPPORT OF
HIS BROTHERS IN THE FIRE.
SERVICE WAS. IT WAS PALPABLE THE
LOVE THEY HAD FOR HIM AND THE
LEADERSHIP THAT HE ALWAYS SHOWED
THEM.
AND HOW PASSIONATE HE WAS FOR
HIS SERVICE.
CORY IVERSON'S WIFE ASHLEY WHO
ALSO SPOKE AT THE SERVICE OF THE
ROCK OF STRENGTH AND FAITH. VERY
SPECIAL SWEET WOMAN.
ACTUALLY WHEN YOU WHEN YOUR
PRAYERS ARE TWO YEARS KNOW THAT
GOD WILL BRING A RAINBOW. AFTER
THE STORM.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING IN
THE MEMORY OF CAL FIRE ENGINEER
KOREA IVERSON OUR HOMETOWN HERO.
THANK YOU MS WALDRON THANK YOU
MEMBERS
THE CLERK WILL NOW READ THE
NAMES OF THE CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE.
VICTOR AT. THE CLOCK WHEN I READ
THE NAMES OF THE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES VICTIMS.
VICTIMS OF THE TUBS FIRE.
KAREN A COCK.
MICHELLE ASSYRIAN.
CARMEN VARIES.
CAROL CON SUEVI.
MICHAEL DARD BACH.
VALERIE EVENTS.
MIKE GREBO.
ARTHUR GRANTS.
SUMIKO GRANT.
DONNA HELPER.
WE WRITE HOLDER.
CHRISTINA HANSON.
TALK TO HOME.
MONTY QURBAN.
VERONICA MCCOMBS.
CARMEN MCREYNOLDS.
LYNN POWELL.
MARILYN RESTS.
SHARON RAY ROBINSON.
MARTY SCHWARTZ.
TOMORROW THE TREES THOMAS.
LINDA TUNIS.
VICTIMS OF THE REDWOOD FIRE.
MOBILE MEN.
ROY BELLMAN.
JANET CAN STAND THOUGH.
ELIZABETH FOSTER.
JAMIE GARDNER.
HI SHEPHERD.
PRESS THE JEAN SHEPHERD.
STEVE STELTER.
MARGARET STEPHENSON.
VICTIMS OF THE ATLAS FIRE.
GEORGE CHENEY.
SALLY LEWIS.
CHARLES RIPPY.
SERRA REBBIE.
THERESA SANTOS.
EDWARD STONE.
VICTIMS OF THE NUNS FIRE.
GARRETT PIES.
BE ROGER.
DANIEL SOUTHERN.
VICTIMS OF THE CASCADE FIRE.
STANLEY COOLIDGE.
DAVID COLE.
ROSEANNE HANNAH.
STANDARD PICCIANO.
AND VICTIMS OF THE THOMAS FIRE.
CORY IVERSON.
VIRGINIA PASILA.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE STAND
AS WE OBSERVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE TO HONOR THE VICTIMS
.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS AS WE CLOSE TODAY AND
LIKE TO SPEAK YOU BRIEFLY AND
FRANKLY.
EVERY YEAR BRINGS ITS CHALLENGES
BUT THE CURRENT YEAR CONTAINS A
CHALLENGE THAT IS MARKEDLY
DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE IT IS WITHIN.
LAST YEAR WE ROSE ABOVE THE
PROVOCATIONS OF THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN NATIONAL ELECTION. AND
PRODUCED A RECORD OF LEGISLATIVE
A RECORD OF LEGISLATIVE
ACHIEVEMENT. UNPRECEDENTED IN
RECENT DECADES.
THIS YEAR WE ARE CALLED UPON TO
RISE ABOVE THE LEGISLATURE'S
RECORD. IN PREVENTING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
WE WILL WORK TO RECTIFY THE
SITUATION I WILL KEEP WORKING
UNTIL I RECORD OF PERFORMANCE
MATCHES THE STANDARDS OF OUR
IDEALS.
THIS CAPITAL COMMUNITY AND I
SPEAK OF BOTH HOUSES
MUST BUILD A COMMUNITY OF ACTIVE
PROTECTORS.
WE MUST PROVIDE THAT PROTECTION
FOR THOSE WHO WORK HERE AND
THOSE WHOSE WORK REQUIRES THEM
TO COME HERE.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
WE MUST DO BETTER.
ON THIS ISSUE WE MUST BECOME
WHAT CALIFORNIA IS ON SO MANY
OTHER ISSUES.
AND EXAMPLE OF HOW TO GO
FORWARD.
I HOPE WE CAN KEEP THIS IN MIND
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS WE
GO ABOUT MAKING THIS IMPORTANT
WORK OF MAKING THIS GREAT STATE.
EVEN GREATER.
TO CALDERON MOVES MR KNOWLEDGE A
SECONDS THAT THE HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY JANUARY
FOURTH AT NINE AM CORAL CAUSE
LIFTED THE HOUSE IS ADJOURNED